I am very excited to be here for a piano
that I hope will be interesting
provocative not provoking and we have
some amazing panelists for you today our
first participant is an associate
professor of psychology at an
neuroscience at New York University and
he conducts research on how group
identities moral values and political
beliefs shaped the mind and brain please
welcome jovan Babel our next participant
is a clinical psychologist at the
Bellevue NYU program for survivors of
torture where she provides clinical care
to individuals and families who have
survived torture and refugee trauma
please welcome Catherine porterfield's
and our final guest today is a social
psychologist also at New York
University's Stern School of Business
whose research examines the intuitive
foundations of morality and how morality
varies across cultural and political
divides please welcome Jonathan hi thank
you guys all for being here today
I think we are in for a fascinating
conversation and I wanted to begin by
kind of setting the parameters of the
discussion so in your mind and I'd like
all three of you to address this
what is extremism you know what when you
say extremism when you think of
extremism in your work what does it mean
to you maybe we can start with J yeah I
would just say it means to me that
someone has a very rigid dogmatic belief
system and they've started to see the
world in black and white and lost any
sense of shades of gray okay okay
yeah I mean I think we probably all
anchor to our own thing that we do in
the world and so I work a lot with
people who have been subject to
extremist acts or themselves have
attempted to or done extremists so I
think of it as sort of you know enacting
or thinking about enacting behavior that
reflects very rigid black and white
viewpoints and I do tend to usually
think it it that veers toward
ideas about violence or at least
oppressing the rights of others John so
as a social psychologist might my test
for what social psychology studies is I
like to start with Homo economicus
imagine a person who only does things
that are in his or her self-interest and
then everything about what we people
actually do that is beyond that that's
social psychology and to the extent that
sometimes we do things that seem
possibly incredibly self-destructive
people are willing to face arrest people
are willing to face violence people are
willing to sometimes even blow
themselves up those are acts so far
beyond our self-interest we tend to
label those as extremism just building
onto Jays definition I would just
caution that we can't identify just the
patterns of thought because we all feel
passionate about certain things so
extreme isn't to some extent is what
your enemies do where we ourselves are
never extremists I think that's I think
that's a really interesting point Jay
would would your work actually back some
of that up because I know you've done
some work on what we ourselves see
ourselves as yeah so to John's point I
have a paper on the psychology of hate
which there's a lot of different
theories floating around that are
several thousands of years old
date back to Aristotle and very little
research on the psychology of hate in
part because it's hard to put it in a
bottle and study it in the lab and so
one thing we did is we ran some
experiments trying to figure out how
people think about hate differently from
other forms of dislike that are extreme
and it seems like it's more negative for
sure there's a difference of degree but
there's also a difference of kind and
the additional ingredient John is
morality and so to take that to the real
world and this might address where
Kate's interests are we analyze the
content on hate websites from 50
different hate groups and those of you
on the panel might know this some of the
very first groups to take advantage of
the internet or hate groups and so if
you look at the content of their
language on their websites
it is moralized that's one thing that
makes it truly different from other
types of complaint forums or negative
types of websites and if you actually
read it carefully it's not just that it
has moral content they see themselves as
Jewish defenders of some set of values
and so these are the people that we
think of as the most reprehensible
members of our society but they
certainly don't see themselves that way
so one of my favorite metaphors for
understanding weird things in society is
the the headline I think it actually
appeared in a British newspaper fog in
channel continent cut off and you know
cuz obviously Britain to say that the
continent was cut off that's looking at
from their perspective okay maybe you
didn't find it fun guys but but it's a
it's a good metaphor for a lot of things
because here we are in this
extraordinary advanced Western secular
civilization which you know really just
sort of came up in the last you know 100
200 years however you want to count it
and we're talking about what those
extremists do when actually I think the
better way to look at this to flip the
lens around and say as a species human
beings for as long as we have any anti
archaeological record human beings have
painted their skins danced around a
campfire worship various animate objects
engaged in violent intergroup
competition and lived a very very
intense ritual Rupesh life that's what
we do that's who we are now what we need
to explain is why would that stop why
did that stop for us for our cultural
ancestors and there's a wonderful book
by barbara ehrenreich the woman who
wrote nickel and dimed
just this fantastic book I don't hear
people talk about called dancing in the
streets
a history of collective joy and she
starts from reading all the explore like
the European explores when they went out
all around the world despite all the
variety of civilizations they went to
pretty much everyone everywhere they
danced around the campfire to rhythmic
music they had all kinds of rites and
rituals and this stuff started a lot of
the great sociologists like Durkheim and
Weber and others this is what we do and
then for some reason and a lot of it has
to do with an advanced commercial
society which were all focused on making
money and trade that dampens down the
extremism you might say that makes us
secular creatures more Homo economicus
really focused on advancing our
self-interest and so sometimes we lose
that and we go back to our normal
extremists that's the way that I would
reframe this almost right now going back
to some of our roots yes absolutely yeah
and so this actually makes me wonder
kind of if we look at extra
over time not just kind of ebbs and
flows but also the definitions of what
is an isn't seen as extreme is there
also kind of a component of that that
because society evolves that we actually
start seeing different behaviors as
extreme or is it something that's always
you know this has always been extreme in
any society I think that some of it
might be a little bit more context
determined what would you guys say about
that yeah I would say that culture and
context play a huge role in what we
define is appropriate or inappropriate
so one example in our lifetimes a moral
issue that's changed a lot is attitudes
towards homosexuality same-sex marriage
gay rights LGBT rights in the last
decade they've completely reversed in
terms of approval versus disapproval and
so what was objectionable in fact
illegal not that long ago is legal and
celebrated and New York's gonna be
having a huge Pride Parade in the near
future and so what was considered an
extreme event so it's always a it's a
minority of the population who is gay so
it's always been outside of the majority
but what how we've defined it and
acceptance of those types of behaviors
has changed dramatically and this is
something that is highly moralized has
historically for a lot of people and so
things change pretty quickly about what
is a legal behavior and unethical
behavior or immoral behavior to
something that is accepted and embraced
and celebrated okay that's okay I just
have it the flip side of it
unfortunately too though is that like if
you look after 9/11 we're sort of normal
practice of Islam became very frequently
labeled extremists by a lot of regular
Americans who got scared and reacted to
a lot of the rhetoric and so the flip
side I think is that what's called
extremists now is actually sometimes of
pathologizing of normal you know
faith-based practice or you know wearing
hijab or you know whatever and so now
that's been labeled extremists whereas
you sort of look at white supremacy
which has always been always been it's
always been that white supremacist have
been looked at as extremists but but you
do yeah
well I mean okay the Klan was not an
extremist organization when it was
founded it was but okay no no IIIi good
point I sort of meant in the last like
maybe I was you're not in our line okay
well that's probably anyway but you're
look at last year we're then sort of
that groups behavior got normalized a
bit and less and and sort of viewed less
as extremists and brought into the
mainstream so it's it's definitely
culturally what's the word sort of
normed by what cultural responses are
yeah so I think just the very word
extremist I mean in the word itself it
tells us that it's a statistical term
it's so it's just relative to what most
people are doing that's extremist so I
think we need to keep in mind that by
definition there's always extremes and
then we can also as a separate or
related conversation we can talk about
the willingness to use violence and
force to get your way that is something
that can be defined more objectively in
some societies that's the norm and in
American society for the in the post-war
years that was very much not the norm we
had a burst of it in the 60s and we're
getting a little bit more of it in the
last couple years on campus not a lot
but so so I would urge this to maybe
even focus on that because that's really
what's a problem for society it's not
that there are people far away it's that
there are people willing to use violence
and force to get their way and do you
think that that's do you think that we
need to differentiate between kind of
that definition in different domains so
like you know we have obviously
religious extremism but there's also
political extremism which you just
alluded to there's cultural extremism
and you know we have all of these
different kind of domain specific areas
and in some of them you might say you
have very negative and pernicious social
effects without any violence like if the
extremism is something about First
Amendment for instance so that's that
can be a extremism but without violence
so do we are we talking does it always
have to be physical violence does it
depend on domain you know is there
differences you know in in the work that
you've done with these sorts of
different types of extremism I'm just
curious to hear all of your all your
thoughts on one kind of that I tend to
focus on process I think the miracle of
our modern
secular society says that we develop
processes I often say thank God we were
settled by the British rather than the
Spanish my friends in Latin America say
that to me too if only we were settled
by the British the British give us
really good institutions the Spanish had
colonial institutions of extraction
terrible for setting up a secular
liberal democracy so the British did a
fantastic job giving institutions you
see this in many former British colonies
but then sometimes those process the
willingness to abide by process and rule
of law
sometimes people violate that because
that's not really who we are as a
species or basic nature is much more
prone to to saying the ends justify the
means and if I'm sure that my side is
right and the courts have ruled that I'm
wrong to hell with the courts
that's normal human psychology and if we
have certain parameters we end up
following the rules we have procedural
justice we don't have violent extremism
and what's breaking down now that we
have a falling off a cliff support for
democratic norms and faith and democracy
falling off a cliff with each new
generation is that there's me a lot less
willingness to respect democratic
process it's gonna get a lot worse the
next couple decades is my prediction I
guess I feel like the only place I've
sort of counted out a bit though is in
my experience working with people who
really have gone over to the fringe of
being willing to enact violence so
whether you know planning an attack or
engaging in something or trying to fly
to a place where they could do that I
guess to a to a person that these are
all been people who've suffered really
extreme trauma and marginalization in
their lives and so systems are not
something that they were raised to
experience as you know beneficent you
know life-giving nurturing you know fill
in the blanks so to them the system is a
joke and it's it's not unlike I think
what you see sometimes in gang
membership which is another kind of
extremism we haven't really talked about
but so the idea I think there's a lot of
people who when they get raised in you
know good enough home with enough
resources and a decent enough community
in school they follow the rules and they
you know they abide by stuff and they
believe in the system you know I mean
when I get a traffic ticket I get
annoyed but I usually pay it or if I
dispute it and that I lose I'm annoyed
even more but I still say okay well
in other words you know I accept that
that is the system and that's probably
because I had a decent enough life
growing up that I believe in systems you
see what I mean you know I I do and I'm
sure that there are there are people
that maybe especially with white
supremacy groups there are people if
there's a guy who's yeah piccoli no
patchouli no there's a guy was a book
now out now he was a neo-nazi and he
left yeah but there certainly are ways
in which people are sort of part of the
underclass under culture on the margins
legally in drugs and petty crime and
then they move on to other things so
that would be the process you're talking
about but there's been a huge amount of
research on terrorist organizations that
generally finds they're educated
middle-class people so there's a lot of
psychological research on the
baader-meinhof gang and yeah Germany in
West Germany
a lot of research on the night the
background of 9/11 terrorists these were
middle class college-educated people
there was no psychopathology and so the
general route that social psychologists
have taken here I'm talking about
especially Clark McAuley and Scott a
trainer to ones that I know I know their
work what they both came to the
conclusion is this has nothing to do
with psychopathology these are people
who get in because of small groups and
attachment to groups it's it's a it's a
real if patrons work shows that
especially the Islamic terrorists or the
or al-qaeda in particular recruited
through soccer groups in Europe so if
you have immigrants from Muslim country
in Spain they'll be in a soccer league
and it's a team it's it's the men of a
team they're the ones who get
radicalized by one guy and before you
know it they're going to different
places for training so it's you have to
look at the small groups I would say as
a social psychologist yeah and JE some
of your work actually talks about that
do you want to address yeah so so I'm
nodding with from John's perspective in
that group identity and the psychology
behind that is I think like the first
ingredient when I think of these types
of issues in society and then I think
the second ingredient is maybe
competition with another group or that
clear enemy so then you get an
us-versus-them and then the third
ingredient and this cuts to a trans work
and yours is morality once it becomes a
sacred domain and you're fighting over
land or some ideology then you have the
kind of to me the three ingredients that
lead to people being willing to engage
in violent behavior so if you
Anker on that definition I think you got
to put in there though
I mean I'm always the clinical unit of
one which is like for me there's always
a sense of self like you you you know
again I have a small and I haven't
researched stuff but you know I've I've
seen a fair number of people who've done
things or tried to do things and you
know for me that the pathology as it
were has usually rested in sense of self
and sense of meaning making about other
people and yeah and let me push on that
and I think that maybe there's a way for
us to blend our ideas together so this
also connects to a trans work with
terrorists if you measure their overlap
with their group so some people have a
very distinct sense of self that's
different from the groups they belong to
and so they're non overlapping circles
people in terrorist groups from his
research anyways finds that those
circles are perfectly overlapping well
he calls it identity fusion yeah their
sense of self isn't a group and that's
why it's easy to engage in things like
self-sacrifice
yeah I'd like to build on that the idea
of identity fusion so it may start with
it could start from an individual
pathology it could start from a small
group but what you often get when people
work together is you get a complete loss
of the sense of self and what really
clued me into this is a is a wonderful
book I read by men and William McNeil
who wrote a book called keeping together
in time and it starts where he he goes
to basic training in Texas this is 1940
or 41 just before the war starts the
u.s. is gearing up and it's very under
equipped they don't have real guns so
they just march up and down all day in
the hot Texas Sun with like sticks and
it seems stupid but by two or three days
of marching he has these self
transcendent experiences and he
describes what is it like when the men
get it when you are moving as a unit
thrilling you lose yourself and so he
wrote he quotes all these other books I
read all these other wonderful books and
I took a quote from one of them that
really describes the loss of self that
men feel in battle and that is a anyway
we have a video I've hired some people
make a video we have like a 90 second
video this is from a book by Jesse Glenn
gray called men and war I think it was
anyway it's it so this is a quote from
grey describing interviews he did with
men and
[Music]
many veterans will admit that the
experience of communal effort in battle
has been the high point of their lives
I passes insensibly into a week my
becomes our an individual faith loses
its central importance I believe that it
is nothing less than the assurance of
immortality that makes self-sacrifice at
these moments so relatively easy I may
fall but I do not die for that which is
real and me goes forward and lives on in
the comrades for whom I gave up my life
so the the conclusion I came to in
writing my book the righteous mind is
that human beings are products of
multi-level selection which is probably
setting off alarms and some of you who
read Richard Dawkins and believed that
written almost level selection that's a
heresy that's totally wrong our human
nature is overwhelmingly the product of
individual level selection our ancestors
were good at competing with other people
in their group that's individual level
selection makes us largely selfish we're
generous to the extent that it ends up
helping us in the long run but but I
believe we have a period of several
hundred thousand years in human
evolution from anywhere from a million
years ago to to the present in which
there was a lot of group versus group
violence or just competition and all of
us in this room are descended from the
groups that didn't get wiped out by
other groups the groups that had
combinations of genetic and especially
cultural adaptations especially religion
that bound them together made them work
as a unit made them fierce in war made
them able to cooperate to in bad times
so I believe that the phrase I use in
the book is that human beings are 90%
chimp and 10% B it's not that our
ancestors had sex with a B it's that
they went through a little bit of a
process of group level selection which
gave us this tribal of group ish overlay
and that's what I'm trying to illustrate
in that video and Jay you've actually
done some work on tribalism and kind of
what happens and how that develops do
you want to talk a little yeah I'll say
yeah this is one of the things that
fascinates me and John I think you call
this the hive switch
and so there's classic research in
psychology that I've followed up on
where basically you flip a coin if I was
a flip a coin and decide that this group
was going to be in one group and this
side of the room is going to be another
group so that's gonna be the red team
and the blue team we could ask each
other by the end of this session how
much you like and identify through group
versus other group and I do this in my
classes all the time and just without
exception people start to say they like
members of their own group more even if
they don't interact with them in these
studies they find that they like their
own group members more even if they
don't see them or know who they are and
humans are distinct among primates in
that we will be pro-social and cooperate
with in-group members who are anonymous
we've never met no other primate will do
that and so there's something about the
human mind that allows us to shift into
this sense of identity and draw these
boundaries with other groups and what we
found is in the scanner so we bring
people in and measure their brain
activation and you start to see
differences emerge within a few minutes
after you do this in people's brains
even very low level automatic responses
in their brain and their amygdala which
is basically detecting things that are
important start to shift from ways of
chunking up the world that were used to
like black and white to in-group and
out-group on the basis of how we flipped
a coin the other thing we found in a
recent paper is the same patterns of
activation in the brain when you flip
this coin and create these groups
predict how you're seeing the world
politically so when we think of
Democrats and Republicans we think well
they have very different policies and
platforms and we've thought about the
world and several decades thinking about
our politics and certainly that plays a
role but there's also this just
foundation of group business and that
the same patterns of the brain that
respond to red team and blue team based
on a coin flip are active when you're
thinking of red team and blue team in
terms of Democrats and Republicans and
so kind of a core root of political
divides and divides and all kinds of
other group which domains nationality
soccer teams religious differences have
are grounded in this kind of basic
psychology the willingness to do
violence part of the group psychology
becomes like for me I'm it just it often
I think roots
into individual development through
childhood and so you know for instance
if we divide the group up and then said
okay now start fighting each other
probably a couple you would refrain you
know right most of you wouldn't do
violence because of this group yeah but
so the willingness to do that for me
starts going back to that developmental
experience that that kid had you know
what was what what did other people mean
to that kid you know were they a source
of fear were they a source of
degradation and humiliation because then
what you're starting to do is wire in to
that kid's brain a sense that other
people are dangerous and other people
are a source of humiliation and then
meanings about that are much easier
attached on to that kid sort of how I
think of the kids I've seen who've
gotten into extreme stuff it's like you
know as they start reading it's like
barnacles they can just attach onto them
easier you know I've got teenagers who
have all kinds of you know crazy ideas
but I don't think you could convince
them you know that that they should go
out and kill people because I hope you
know they've had a good enough
upbringing but that doesn't attach to
meanings that they feel in their body
and in their mind from having been
degraded been marginalized been
humiliated so I just feel like I always
have to pull towards that individual
psychology part you know I'll defer to
John and then I have a comment about
that okay the question is given what you
just said about Red Team Blue Team how
quickly we divide up this minimal groups
research I'd like to ask your opinion of
what we're doing in high schools and
colleges as we teach kids identity
identity politics how we encourage them
for much of the 20th century we're
headed towards a regime of minimizing
racial identity and maximizing the sense
of shared identity and and trying to get
beyond racial divisions and the last few
years there's been a huge surge in
programming and efforts to directly
teach various theories and it's a lot of
initiate a lot of orientation and
university is now and a lot of high
school programs are encouraging kids to
be more identified and to see each other
in terms of their category membership
what do you think of this so I don't
know the specifics of this program and
and this is going to be a whole
minefield I'll walk into now I've been
happier that I work in the prisons both
okay so I'm not familiar with how this
is happening in high
school so I'm just gonna express
ignorance about that what I would say is
this
so I've studied this many times in the
context of race if you create mixed race
teams people start to show positive
attitudes to whoever is in their team
whether they're black or white and so
that's a positive benefit of these
support and identities and that's been
shown over and over again by many other
labs and research teams other than than
my own so that's a robust finding and a
really positive element of group
business and identity that we could it
has this dark side but also has a bright
side that we can come together to
accomplish right the more we emphasizes
superordinate identities and common
goals the more you can get past any kind
of reasons yeah and so that but then
there's one qualification of that in the
literature which is that when minority
groups are expected to subsume into the
majority group that can cause tension
say feel like they're having to adopt
all the values of the majority group and
so it turns out it works best for them
if they can retain their identity and
celebrate their identity so this is I'm
Canadian and so this is part of multi
cultures in mccanna de which is that you
have a broader Canadian identity when
the Olympics are on everybody's turn for
the Canadian hockey teams but at the
same time that you celebrate the
subordinate identities that you have and
that we celebrate difference and so if
you can I think that it works best
there's a couple labs who found this it
works best if you can do both well but I
think if you're just focusing on the
lower order identities without
nourishing the high order one that would
be a direction I wouldn't recommend
that's right and that's the direction
we're heading that's one of the reasons
I think things can get a lot worse in
this country yeah but I think if you can
do both and I've got leaders in the
country can promote both and I think
that that the research would suggest
that's a better pathway to success
I agree well it's not unlike what we did
when I mean when you have a kid in front
of you when when I do that I'm working
with who's thought about going and
joining an extreme organization and
doing something violent I mean the way I
work usually with a team towards helping
him or her think about another option is
not to try to talk him or her out of his
their beliefs you know yeah don't think
that that's not the way your you know
your faith really wants you that never
works but what we usually do is work to
build relationships build true
engagement on
kinds of you know what we call plurality
right so so thinking about the world as
a world that's better with multiple
points of view by showing it and living
it with the kid with you know by showing
them that hey I'm a you know I'm a
Brooklyn New York you know mom of three
kids and I really care about hearing
about your ideas and your thoughts let's
engage that that's sort of more a way
towards I think breaking that the the
in-group rigidity to you know so it's
interesting parallel yeah I wonder if we
can segue do we have an image of the two
echo chambers online so this is a study
that I ran with Billy Brady and Julian
wills and John Jost in my lab here at
NYU we analyzed over half a million
tweets of regular people discussing
hot-button political issues like the
ones were talking about here same-sex
marriage climate change
gun control online and what we found is
when they were using moral emotional
words like anger hate disgust in their
tweets for every additional moral
emotional word in a tweet it was about
fifteen to twenty percent more likely to
be retweeted so that's how things get
contagious online at least what we found
in our data and the other thing though
so that's a positive you ever want to
like have a successful social media
campaign you can find some moral
emotional language about the poker table
excellent
so that spreads information it's more
likely to be Reshard by others but we
can figure out what your political
leaning is based on who you follow and
who follows you so if you follow Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton we can infer
that you're probably pretty liberal if
you follow Donald Trump and George Bush
you're more likely to be conservative
and so you can plot people based on
their political beliefs and what you
find is when they're using this moral
emotional language this is what you see
is that it's going viral but only within
these echo chambers and so you get
people just talking to themselves and
you get what looks like a division and
so we don't know if this is the more
emotional language is causing this or or
what that's one thing you don't get from
social media but it's kind of the exact
pathology that we're talking about and
so in another study I ran with with Mena
Jakara she
the first author we actually showed
people social networks that look like
the one you just saw
and then measured their empathy for
in-group members and out-group members
and if they saw that the two groups look
like that
they suddenly showed very little empathy
for the out-group if you show them a
social network that looks integrated and
overlapping their empathy suddenly
increases for the out-group
and this was not in a political context
this is with flipping a coin and
creating two teams but I feel kind of
bad because that image that I just
showed you actually went viral and we
publishes paper but if anything that
perpetuates the problem because people
start to see the group's is more divided
than they then they maybe really are and
that it makes them less likely to
empathize with other groups they start
to think we're not connected in any way
we don't have shared social networks or
friends and so it's kind of we're in
maybe this is why John thinks is getting
worse I would love to be in a virtuous
cycle but we're in a negative spiral and
it's just mutually reinforcing now
that's I think this is a really nice
connection back to the point about about
process if you think about a democratic
society and this amazing thing we've
done of building a ethnically and
religiously and racially diverse
democratic society that was the envy of
the world for much of the 20th century
and yeah this really complex system and
then you you reach in you change a
couple of the parameters it's so it's
sort of like imagine like the whole
universe is it held together and there's
25 constants and physics and you know
and it match if you reached in and you
suddenly just like you took the
gravitational constant and you just
multiplied it by a thousand like what
would happen a universe like I don't
know find out well you know what are we
connected everybody that's gonna
everybody everyone can talk to everyone
back and but just you know multiply they
don't increase the constant of relations
by a thousandfold what could what could
go wrong I don't let's find out but so
the plots can go right select Facebook I
mean they're very idealistic and there's
a lot of good that happens so I think
but I think they didn't because they had
this very optimistic view with what if
we just you know connect everybody and
if only there was no you know there were
no nations and no religions to and you
know so but yeah I think that because
human nature is prone to this violent
tribalism
I think social media on net has been a
huge negative we don't know not
confident that judgment but I fear that
it has been a huge they were just
amplify mean cuz I hey this is what I
hear all the time when I'm talking to
these kids and they're telling me how
they became you know interested and you
know radicalized essentially and it's
just so sad I mean because what they
talk about is sitting in their room and
these are kids with emotional problems
they've you know they have usually as I
said had childhood trauma they have
trouble with empathy they have trouble
feeling good about themselves and so
they sit in their room and they have a
constant feed of language that enhances
their sense of grievance and that the
failures that they have are related to a
larger mission and they are alienated
then from from a group that might say
yes there's grievance yes there's things
that have been wrong but let's let's do
something to fight let's do something to
fix it let's you know they get alienated
from that and they become you know echo
chamber into this very very malignant
language and it's and ultimately it you
know it fuels a lot of what they decide
to do and it's really destroy and then
they actually have contact with real
people it's not just websites and you
know videos which are very very
disturbing but they there's people out
there who will communicate and say yeah
yeah do stuff right so I think we're
probably a psychologist I think we'll
all agree that a really important thing
in everyone's life and especially
adolescents is prestige is what people
think of you in your peer group and
there's a really useful concept called a
an externality in a kind of socking
externality is where you know if I buy
something but I don't pay the full cost
I'm actually every time I buy I'm
actually imposing costs on others and so
pollution is like that's also things
will invent well social media has set up
vast vast externalities in which in my
group I want to get prestige and I can
get prestige by saying hateful things
about her and I don't know her I don't
care about her but let's just all attack
her and whoever can attack from most
viciousness creatively with the most
nasty memes that person gets more
prestige and none of us care what
happens to her and so this I think is
what most alarms me about in social
media is that it used to be that a lot
of our conversations were to the person
that we were talking to but a whole
generation is being raised online where
they're not really talking to each other
they're talking to display to others and
their talk has all kinds of bad effects
but they're not possible for that so
there's a gigantic market failure in
this sort of the social communication
market one thing I'll tell teenagers who
I work with is including my own children
is if you're having a strong emotion
about a person or about yourself and
you're looking at a screen you need to
get up and walk away from the screen and
deal with another human because a strong
emotion and screens are rarely a good
combination I'm not talking about
watching a movie and you feel something
I'm talking about you're feeling rage or
you're feeling humiliated and small and
you just keep at it you stay in that
loop that's never a good thing
especially for teenagers they're not
developed their frontal lobe is not
there yet in the mmm maybe this is not
the worst you know the worst moment of
my life and I should go do you know
maybe there's actually gonna be someone
here my daughter is eight and last month
it was a crazy thing that happened she
was sitting on the sofa and she said
daddy can you come take my iPad away I
can't take my eyes off so this actually
reminds me of some of the work you've
done Jay on depersonalization you
out-groups
can you talk a little bit about that and
about how kind of those two areas of
your research might actually end up
overlapping and amplifying it yeah so
thanks Maria um so one thing as I'm
hearing these conversations one reason I
love to have these debates in person on
a panel like this is because you can
contextualize what you're saying with
richer language but also with your body
language and smiling and nodding and so
you can agree with somebody in as we've
been doing in a comfortable way that you
move the conversation forward and you
identify where you share reality and
where you disagree whereas online
I hate debating people on Twitter and
I'm on Twitter a lot and I like sharing
stuff and having signed to vendors has
been very gracious like your Twitter you
should be following him was it J van
babe what is yeah babe oh he's he's a
great science tweeter oh good but I will
not debate people on Twitter and here's
why because you lose all the context
there's not enough characters to add
nuance and to say well I agree with you
on this part John but I disagree here
there's just not the space for it the
other thing is it's happening in public
and so reputation management and status
is on the line in a way that is
especially in view if you think of
thousands of
or if something gets taken if context
and retweeted by a lot of people it's
horrifying if it's happened you and it's
happened to me I'm sure that's happened
to you and I've had lots of friends and
they're just horrified and they want to
unplug or they shut down their account
after and it's the worst possible
context and you also don't get the human
emotion you can't see their face see if
they're joking or being sarcastic or
trying to attack you whereas you can
sense that in person and bridge the gap
much easier and so as we've moved our
human interactions around hot-button
issues like politics and morality online
you've gotten rid of all the things that
help us deescalate conflict and have
civility or most of them I think and
then the other thing I want to speak to
and this is my main concern of social
media is if you go to the Wall Street
Journal they have this great page called
red feed blue feed you can pick a topic
like immigration or gun control and it
will show you what's being seen by
somebody on the extreme left or the
extreme right in this country and it's
horrific all the feeds and how different
they are but also the types of news
they're drawing from are not the
Associated Press it's from obscure news
sites that are hyper partisan and and
part of it is because there's an
incentive structure built into the money
that social media companies make which
is you get a lot of clicks for things
that are extreme and people are more
glued to their screen like your poor
child if you feed them back stuff that
fits with their belief system ideology
and so my hope actually and I think that
this is there's more research going on
and I'm hoping that they find a solution
is for companies like Facebook to update
their algorithms in ways that feed
people quality information and
deescalate the partitioning of society
into these extreme chambers really well
for Pepsi when they tried to create
healthier foods okay didn't last long
they had a stop I'm an optimist so yeah
well I was also thinking about your work
which which is very scary to me that
when we see someone as an out-group
member we don't see them as having in
mind and can you talk a little bit about
how we actually and because I'm what I'm
worried about hearing what you guys are
saying about social
this might actually amplify some of
those propensity to not see the other as
even human okay so do we have the video
or the image for this of the morphing
between a human and a doll so this was a
study that I ran in my lab Lior hackle
was the first author and we got all
these great morphs from Christine Lucero
a colleague of ours and she had found
dolls or that looked like human and
matched them up and then used computer
software to morph them across the
spectrum from a hundred percent human to
represent human a hundred percent doll
and you could go from one hundred
percent human to ninety percent human
eighty percent human along the spectrum
and what we found is at the moment
people are part of a team or a group
again you can flip a coin and create
groups that the point at which they
start to see a face look human takes
more humaneness and so if it's an
out-group member you start to see the
person looking human around 60%
humaneness but if they're an in-group
member it's like fifty five percent so
in other words it takes less humaneness
to see somebody as having a mind if
they're an in-group member and we found
this also with NYU students and this is
really only among the the students who
are highly identified so if they don't
care about their group and at NYU you
have some students who could care less
about NYU there's here because they want
to be in New York so for them they don't
show this effect but the moment you
start to identify your group the effect
actually looks quite big and so what we
think is happening as part of this
broader literature on dehumanization
which has been in the news a lot lately
about how we talk about other groups if
you don't see another group as having
you know experience or emotions
that's tends to be if you look at really
horrible experiences in human history
like the genocide in Rwanda or Nazi
Germany what you see is propaganda that
tells you this group is is rats or this
room is cockroaches and what that is
doing is dehumanizing people and that
allows you to harm somebody and this
goes to a point I just want to bridge
you made earlier Kate which is that a
lot of people we flip a coin here we can
create groups there's God could not
going to be any violence you're totally
right violence is really hard and so in
World War one when they looked at the
weapons in trench warfare that were
fired very few people actually fired
their gun they stood there over the
trench and made it look like they were
shooting but they were staring at
somebody across the
the trenches and when you see somebody's
face it's very hard for normal humans to
pull the trigger and harm somebody so
our military's got really good at
training people to to shoot to kill
people but it took a lot of work because
it does not come naturally to most
people and so if you have some existing
pathology or background of trauma you're
gonna be the subset of people who are
likely to absolutely use these cues to
then do something bad but this is part
of when you see propaganda in these
things it's setting the stage if you
were to dehumanize a group to allow you
to be more comfortable harming them yeah
yeah I mean the the the other
psychological concept that links up for
me regarding the kids and young people
I've worked with who tended to make
these terrible decisions is a sense of
what we call in clinical psych we call
emotional dysregulation and that is sort
of not being able to deal with your
feelings not being able to recognize
them not being able to name them not
being able to process them not being
able to then recognize them in others so
now obviously we're you know the
emotional dysregulation leads very
clearly into empathy issues and so the
idea of kids who are raised in a if you
raise a kid you know abusing them
humiliating them and I mean I'm talking
about kids who've watched you know their
their father's just viciously brutalize
their mothers in the home and this
little kid is cowering literally in the
corner so he's he's being traumatized by
the most you know the closest people in
his life his parents especially the
father
you know that kid develops an emotional
regulation problem most likely I mean
the the the couple kids I'm thinking of
as I put that example together uh you
know what they develop what he develops
is an inability to handle his feelings
and therefore feelings become very very
overwhelming and frightening to him and
so when he has a feeling he's going to
be less likely to be able to deal with
it and so then again put him in that
echo chamber where the kinds of things
that are being stoked are anger and rage
and you know we're being humiliated you
know us white people us whoever fill in
the blanks and you have then a kid who
doesn't have anything to do with it it's
confusing it's upsetting you know so to
me that emotional dysregulation that
comes out of a bad childhood is a really
critical piece usually to understanding
kids who grow up and are willing to do
violence
yeah for sure for sure so so right now
we're kind of talking about a lot of the
the negative issues here when oj said he
was an optimist well let's try to let's
try to harness some of that optimism
John you you seem the most pessimistic
so can you kind of elaborate a little
bit on that sorry guys but also then
kind of challenge yourself and say is
there any reason for optimism right now
or are we or are we actually being
stupid if we're being optimistic but
there are reasons for optimism in that
if you just read Steve Pinker's book
Johan Norberg has another book ron
bailey has written about this and the
long-term trends for human history are
amazingly positive and getting better
very very fast and so if I were you know
looking at the human race or things for
Humanity in general it's incredibly good
how quickly things are getting better
and war is dropping violence is dropping
so there's a lot of reasons for optimism
many of the big indicators about the
United States obviously violence's is
way down a lot of other things are good
furthermore if I if you ask me a hundred
years from now are things gonna be
better or worse for people in the United
States I would say better hundred years
now they're almost certain to be better
probably a lot better but if you ask me
about the helps of our political system
and what are the odds that they will
still be a single country called the
United States with the same 50 states in
the same US Constitution revised only
through an amendment process three years
ago I would have said 99 point something
percent I mean 50 years Mel's gonna be
the same country and now I would say
maybe 80% 70% like I would bet that will
still be here but it's quite conceivable
that we won't because things can go bad
very quickly and what I mean by that is
you know it is if you accept the picture
I gave of human nature that we evolved
to be small group tribalists and that's
the way we evolved we're able to live in
different ways we're able to live in a
large multi-ethnic secular democracy we
know that because we did it but it may
be that the margin of error for that
might be very small and there was a
nobody is old enough now to remember but
for the 1940s rather than late 30s but
the post-war world in America had a huge
surplus of centripetal forces things
binding us together it was historically
unprecedented I mean even the media that
we've never had a media environment that
really pulled us all on to the paint
same page except for the post-war
several decades
we reduced immigration and the 20s
immigration as many good things for the
economy but it makes it harder to have a
shared set of norms so everything was
lined up for maximum centripetal force
for about 40 years after the war and
then gradually those things started
drifting away and so when I look at the
when I look at how much young people
trust trust democratic institutions
trust the government trust each other
when look at what they think about
America is it a good country is it
something they're proud of when I look
at all these things it's quite possible
that the founding fathers fear that this
whole thing could blow up like every
previous democracy had that the founding
fathers fears if you read the Federalist
Papers in Federalist 10 that those fears
I think we're quite warranted and it's
possible that we're now operating
outside of the parameters own in which
this is a stable democracy I'm not
saying that we are just saying it's
really possible that we are small
countries if you have a small country
where people have a sense of shared fate
and there but for the grace of God go I
and if you need help I'll help you
because if I need help you'll help me
well that's why Scandinavian countries
are able to have these amazing welfare
states so small there's just an article
New York Times this week Neil gross
about is is are big countries harder to
have democracies in and I agree with him
the answer is yes
so if you have a very large very diverse
country what holds it together what
leads people to accept the process what
leads people to accept that oh the other
side won the election okay let's go you
know rule a law let's go with it
and now we still we're still holding it
together there was a while after Trump
election where you know that looked as
though things could that many people
might not accept it so there are a lot
of ways that things could go bad if the
economy were to tanked if there were to
be any sort of a nuclear exchange or
even just a grid going down if things
got really bad
there are a lot of ways in which things
might be more fragile than we think yeah
okay what about you from an individual
level I'm doing pretty darn pessimistic
sorry okay are negative chairs here but
my problem I mean I I really toil in the
world of human cruelty I mean that's
kind of what I do and because I work at
a clinic for people who are fleeing war
zones and fleeing you know situations of
Frank torture and so I spend a lot of
time looking at the cost of really
incredible dehumanization and cruelty
let me save one optimistic thing so you
don't all go running screaming out of
them I mean I I have great faith in us
as beings I think humans are amazing I
also think that that I actually think
that recovery from you know virulent
extremism and virulent hate is possible
I mean I've seen it I've worked with
with guys who have turned it around and
changed and it's a beautiful thing
when you see a person link their
hate-filled ideas that they used to have
when you see them understand that that
came from their hurt it really is an
amazing thing because you watch the
person kind of break it down and say you
know I don't want to be this way why did
this why'd this happen to me
so that's the good stuff but but my
problem is that I do believe that the
connectivity of the human race is is a
problem and that there was there was
something better when you couldn't be 24
hours a day having contact with
strangers all over the world and
anything goes I think that really is bad
for the human psyche because there are
dark corners of the psyche that are best
left either to oneself or maybe whoever
your people are or maybe hopefully your
shrink but now there's no dark corner
that you can't find a mirror to on on
the Internet and then and as one of you
guys are saying it starts amplifying and
so for my work you know
these are kids who would have been the
kids who I work with often are young
that I say kids they're often young
people in their 20s but who you know
they probably would have not done great
in life and me if there was an internet
and maybe you know not had a great
career and maybe used drugs and alcohol
and but they wouldn't have been able to
glom on to something so toxic that then
ruined their lives
essentially if there
hadn't been internet I'm not talking
about canceling the internet but I'm
just saying that for me the human
connectivity it's I I think it's too
much for for the psyche when there's so
much vulnerability and cruelty out there
so I'm not too optimistic myself okay
I'm just positionally optimistic I'm
also Canadian everyone say that that's a
larger country than the United States
and they have a functioning liberal
democracy there's obviously some
important differences but we just had
the Prime Minister here a couple days
ago giving a talk at our graduation and
he was encouraging debate and discourse
and civil discussion between people who
disagree and I feel like that is part of
it can be part of the norm in in
countries that care to preserve it and
that it's actually been fascinating to
watch I've been studying fake news and
and this kind of weird echo chambers and
the belief systems that are impervious
to logic and an argument in the last
year a couple years and I I agree that
those are part of human nature and that
we've inherited those from our ancestors
in part because they serve solve certain
problems that allowed them to survive
and so we we carried that around with us
but I also wonder if our pessimism comes
from observing a small number of extreme
people who get a lot of attention so
those are the people you see on that
problem at your clinic yeah and those
are the people that john sees who
respond to you in social media or we
observe talking about to work we're
constantly holding up people who have
the most extreme attitudes rather than
looking at where the median is and what
the consensus is and what the
distribution is we don't see the people
in the middle even though that's 60 to
70 percent of the population what we see
the people on the extreme is making the
most noise or engaging in the most
outrageous behavior and we point to them
as examples of what the other side is
all like but the other side is not
actually that homogeneous and so I do
believe that we might have a missed
Sep ssin of what the consensus belief is
on a lot of these types of issues that
are divisive and so I end up finding the
data from Pinker fairly compelling that
we're on a good trajectory and we built
stronger institutions and I know like
the people at Facebook are hard at work
like right now trying to fix their
algorithms to promote better
interactions and two point three two
point three four billion people are on
social media now and and and Molly
Crockett has this great research showing
most of us get our moral outrage from
social media now so we're that's true as
opposed to the real world so almost a
third to almost half of the world's on
social media and that's where they're
getting outraged so that's happening but
it's within our power to tweak the
technology that we've built that's
divided us and so I again I'm optimistic
and I know people who are working on
that problem and they're serious about
trying to to fix it and so to me that's
a problem it's solvable and that's an
institution that we can construct and
tweak and build in better ways to
promote interests that we actually share
and values that we all care about one of
the things that I'm hearing you know
from all of you is that you know human
nature is not all rosy you know we have
yes we we kind of suck in a lot of ways
when as a lot of where we come from
sucks and these are forces to be
countered that and that things like
social media are almost bringing us back
to some of our more primal moments in a
way even though you know they bring us
together and yet they've also torn us
apart by by kind of doing this so so I
guess then the question is and you've
done some work on kind of increasing
empathy among people you know how do we
given this new landscape you know I
don't I honestly I'm not optimistic
about getting you know the social media
companies to settle me tweak algorithms
because you've done the work that shows
why not you know they want clicks and
they want money and they want they want
moral contagion yeah it's actually good
for social media and I don't see you
know we live in a capitalist society I
don't see them going against their
self-interest in that way so let's
assume that we can't do that then what
do we what do we do how do we kind of
acknowledge this kind of dark side of
human nature that's not going
anymore and that's kind of being
amplified and how do you then kind of
start working on some of the things that
you've tried to find in a lab on
creating empathy and trying to kind of
counter some of those negative forces
yeah so again I think that we instead of
retreating from technology so you wanna
your your the instinct that your your
kid had it was your daughter John who
shut this down and you're saying maybe
it's unplugged Internet I would lean in
to those technologies and think
carefully about like how do we create
better discourse what are they so when
we think right now so here's the thing
that I think that Facebook and Twitter
have done that backfired the only thing
you can really do is favorite something
or or like it and then you can express
those specific emotions but even if you
express anger people I think assume that
you're expressing it in solidarity with
them
and so what that means is if John posts
something extreme he gets you know 100
likes but no dislikes well because
that's unavailable to him but imagine
that he post something extreme and he
got a hundred likes and 200 dislikes he
probably wouldn't post something along
those lines again but were we've
obscured all that information from John
so all he sees is then when I post
something extreme I get it way more like
some when I post something very
reasonable and and tame and so when
people are getting the reinforcement
signals and and basically learning Klotz
classic reinforcement learning from
their interaction on social media and
it's it's social reinforcement which we
care about more cuz it's signal status
and bout and being valued in your
community imagine if we just added back
in a dislike and so you can see when
you're doing something that's divisive
you actually see you it instantaneous
feedback from everybody your network
don't post any of that stuff again
because you're really obnoxious to the
rest of us and so I think that would be
a disincentive to post divisive things
right now we don't have that well
YouTube has it and if does it encourage
okay okay so another thing the audience
is homogeneous yeah so so YouTube has it
yeah but I mean I don't know how that's
playing out with people who are posting
on YouTube but the comments section is
terrible on YouTube all agree so so well
who knows if that could work we will see
but I
I would place my money that that would
help at least a little bit it might not
solve the problem another thing you
could do is they made retweeting really
easy on on Twitter so now it's a click
and now if I if you post something Kate
and I'm like oh man that gets me so
worked up I'm gonna share this it takes
me one second there's no friction there
and also what they've done
technologically is got rid of my
capacity for our the likelihood that I
engage in reasoning about what I ought
to do in this situation cuz I'm on my
phone I see it it's a click it used to
be harder to retweet something and so
you had to engage in more effort go
through two steps to do that and so it
would it would take very little for them
to put a friction back in to force
people to rely on something less than
their kind of intuition about what to
send out or their emotional automatic
gut response so those are the smallest
things but it would take next to nothing
to to do those and here's what I would
say to do John and maybe this would
convince you more is these companies can
pilot they can pick 10 buttons one out
of a hundred people to update their
technology on see the effects of it and
then if it works scale it and so they do
this stuff all the time with a/b testing
and so if my ideas my intuitions are
wrong my hunches are wrong don't do them
but at least be testing out a bunch of
different strategies and when something
works then then pilot pilot it and then
scale it so that's why I think that
these are actually more solvable than we
think
sorry that's all I got you know I'm I'm
all about AM analog and micro which is
like get in a room with people where
there is you know enormous hurt and
humiliation and pain and get people in
front of each other I mean and and start
to find ways to rebuild trust and to
build empathy I mean it sounds really
cornball but but you know it's it's it's
it's a little bit the if you only have a
hammer everything looks like a nail I
mean a lot of things to me are about the
dehumanization that we're really able to
do very easily in current times and so
I'm a big believer that you can break
you can rehumanize or people by by
putting them in front of each other
whether it's across faith or gender or
race or sexuality or god forbid politics
you know it's it's for me one of the one
of my only ways I can
vision things happening that change
because I've seen it happen so yeah and
on that note about the importance of
personalization actually would like to
welcome someone else on stage so there's
someone in the audience today who has an
a little bit too personal experience
with extremism we have a journalist
Jerry Van Dyke and he was held captive
by the Taliban for 45 days in 2008 so
Jerry if you could please join us for a
few minutes - so Jerry if you wouldn't
mind just starting off by telling us a
little bit about your experience I think
it'd be background initially uh in the
early 1980s I went to Afghanistan as a
reporter for The New York Times and I
lived with then called the Mujahideen
who are today the leaders of the Taliban
and so in I was hired by CBS after on
day after 9/11 and I was actually I was
teaching a class here on political Islam
in 2006 and then got hired away or I
chose to leave because they're making a
movie in Hollywood called Charlie
Wilson's War and I remember spending
time up in the mountains in Morocco with
Charlie Wilson and we were talking about
a man named Jill Aladeen Haqqani and
Jelani and Akane today is the arguably
he's certainly the head arguably the
head of what is in this includes Isis
the most devastatingly effective
certainly the most politically powerful
anti Western jihadist group in the world
and I lived with him in the 1980s in
Charlie Wilson refused to say a bad
thing about them he could not leave the
time in the past when they were all one
group and so after finishing that New
York Times books division contacted me
and said the tribal areas of Pakistan
are like a blank space on the map
and the CIA does not seem to know where
bin Laden is can you go there and it was
what I had been wanting to do because I
wanted to go back and find a Connie I
wanted to find the man I lived with
before who saved my life three times and
I wanted to find out because I knew is
when I lived with him
there was an Egyptian Army Major who
came one day and stayed with us
this is 1981 when I was a young man and
I'm positive today because somebody from
West Point went once came to me after a
book I wrote in 2010 about my
experiences came out and he said we're
still trying to find this man one of the
absolute first leaders and we don't know
him I don't know he used a codename when
I was with him of al-qaeda they still
haven't been able to find but the point
I'm trying to make is and to get to your
point was I wanted to do what they asked
me to do because they didn't they
thought it was and many people have said
to me it was suicidal that I was going
to go back and find the minge war once
our friends who are today our enemies
and so in doing so I went up I was long
hair and beard and living along the
afghan-pakistani border as I had done
when I was a kid wanting to return to
the romance the excitement the sense of
purpose clearly the romance of that time
and romance will kill you and it was on
my fifth trip across I broke the law as
the FBI told me when I got out because I
crossed the border i living with i would
go with the taliban and every single
time they kept a word every single time
they said they would take me from point
A to point B or do this or did that and
they did that until they didn't when I
was betrayed and so in on February 16th
I crossed the border with my with my
well just before we crossed
my guide asked me if I were told me said
pay the driver who took us there you go
him money and I said yes Ivan paid him
for the last week and I went up to him
to give him the money and the first time
and I've had experience in Afghanistan
over many years first time an Afghan
hugged me and kissed me on the cheek and
he said oh tape I'm on go with God I
didn't realize that it was a Judas guess
that I was being betrayed by people who
are once our friends and the fact in and
I had an FBI psychiatrist and I'm I'd
want to go into longer trying to this
real quickly
an FBI psychiatrist that was imposed
upon me when I got out said one of the
principal reasons for today we call PTSD
is betrayal that why do some men and
people in war over centuries wide only
some people have trouble with BTS what
we now call PTSD called mold or World
War one shell shock and so forth its
betrayal and so I was we went up into
the mountains and took many hours and
we're walking through a Abell and I saw
a small tinge of black and the new it
wasn't a black sheep I saw moved behind
a rock and I knew it was what it became
within about 30 seconds it was a black
turban Mohammed wore black turban the
Taliban wear black turbans and Taliban
mean by the way Taliban is the plural of
Tala Tala beans seeker and Persian or in
Pashto and Arabic plural Taliban seekers
students seekers of God and so I was sat
down on a rock they always came
screaming down the mountain Kenna Kenna
and get down I watched my bodyguards
rifles come down on them I said I'm dead
I'm dead put me on a ridge
tied me blindfolded me when you're
blindfolded all your sense of
masculinity all your sense of power gone
I waited for their I heard the rifle
[ __ ] that I was like a sheep it was too
much in shock and then they took us down
a mountain put me in a car
couple hours later we arrived the way up
in the mountains brought me into a room
and I would they separated me from the
others and I got into the room they um
took off the blindfold and I realized
that was not alone my two bodyguards and
my interpreter who in who my guide who
had betrayed me we're still there I was
still part of a group and the first
question they asked me was who is your
father my father I was always trying to
pretend I was one of them not different
but I had to well my father's name is I
was in a deep tribal culture and the
most important thing and most important
question in Afghanistan was and always
will be in a tribal nation is who is
your father who was your grandfather
that today the Pakistani government has
assassinated up to a thousand tribal
leaders trying to create and what there
Jay and John and Kate were talking about
is a brand new Puma a brand new
community a brand new tribe separate
from a blood tribe which al-qaida is a
part of it's a Taliban or a part of
which all Qaeda throughout the Middle
East are all apart of and I've been
spending the last few years writing a
book about this is the it's a sense of
solidarity away from your your your
tribe to create a brand new tribe and
they wanted me ultimately to join that
try but during that time the hardest
part you know get to this and in this
real quickly the hardest part and it's
very interesting that I talked with guy
named Terry way to you if some of you
may recall this getting hit by Hezbollah
in 1987 captivity for four years and he
wanted to know about mock executions and
that's what we talked about was mock
executions it's the what bothered me
more than anything what frightened me
more than anything was the fact that the
the been behind me
I was the next person kidnapped after
Daniel Pearl
why was I not slaughtered I mean Daniel
Perot was slaughtered they gave me I
took my camera and the small CBS Sony
camera and they of course took
everything and then they came in in the
room that one night and the men went
behind me in sunglasses and Kalashnikovs
and banana clips and their fatigue
jackets and the the lead commander took
his took my small Sony camera and he
said how do I turn this on so you're
gonna want me to help you fill my own
execution and then they took the knife
out that long I used it to slaughter
sheep and slaughter water buffalo the
only difference between it's all the
difference in the world and I should not
even say it between me and jim foley and
steven sotloff they put my knife back
down the hardest thing was for me to
lift my back up jim foley steven sotloff
peter kassig
kept their heads up there and their
chins high their back straight and they
looked they're killers they looked us in
the eye it is a what I gained more than
anything else from that time was and I
think the reason I was not killed was
because I looked him in the eye and I
said ultimately okay
it's gene you and me go Jim Foley was
gone
Stephen Salah they had all left us when
you're in a situation like that
everything becomes primal you live in a
reptilian world you fight over food you
fight over space you fight over you
don't fight actually but you you become
very territorial and you you don't
engage in fist fights but you do not
have any sense of solidarity it's every
man for himself to survive the
FBI psychiatrist also said to me there
two types of torture mental and physical
mental last longer does it I don't know
is it better to eat your fingernails
taken out or is it is it the long-term
psychological battle that goes on I
think for someone like the president it
was a draft dodger who who had like vice
president before him are two before him
Cheney both of whom are draft dodgers
supporting torture is and to criticize a
man who went through torture and have
his people stand up and praise that it's
it's it's a need to try in my view to
try and impress upon us how tough they
are because the one thing that I learned
and nothing I learned about that is
humility the ingratitude that I'm alive
and I had a
I was eventually released and I was
brought out came back and the FBI took
over my life psychiatrist and the FBI
took over my life I was not allowed to
say anything for two years couldn't talk
to anybody had to keep it quiet
and the poison deeper and deeper and
deeper and then in 2012 and I still
worked with CBS and they would not let
me go east of Turkey and I knew I had to
come back and try to make myself viable
so I got a contract from a publisher and
and from a national security policy
Foundation gave me some money and I went
back to do a study on the Akane Network
it's killed more people than Isis 40
years now they've been at it throughout
the greater Middle East during that time
I watched steven sotloff and jim foley
be executed and i just decided to go
back and find out who really kidnapped
me and why and i wrote a book about it
and came out last October but during
that time going back to various strange
and unknown ways I still haven't quite
put together it became known and I'm the
door was open for me to meet with the
Akane Network and I went back to see
them in April 2015 secretly and I went
alone and I was scared and he said to me
Ibrahim Haqqani don't worry you were
with us during jihad if you have no
friends in the world you can always come
and stay with us
we are your friends and then he told me
a story about one time coming to the US
and he said he went to Texas I said what
did Texas did you go to see Charlie
Wilson said yeah how is Wilson Charlie I
said he died Oh
God rest his soul the bond was still
there
today I'm the interlocutor to a degree
between the hostages they are holding in
the United States and I've gone back I'm
seeing them again so I'm somewhere in
between I cannot give up my fondness for
them that they saved my life
because I used her Connie's name
constantly with my kidnappers to try and
stay alive so which group do I belong to
I'm American but I don't hate them one
man's terrorist is another man's what
freedom fighter so-and-so Haqqani said
to me one day
we haven't changed only you have changed
thank you so much Jerry looks
[Music]
and we now are going to open it up we
only have a few minutes but we want to
open it to questions from the audience
for any of the panelists or Jerry so
going back to that video that you showed
with the World War 2 veterans do you
think the military do you think we train
the military to become extremists and do
you think that's moral no I don't think
we train the military become extremists
I think that there I've spoken a couple
times at West Point that's the service
that I know best is there's a really
intense moral culture of service and
honor that doesn't mean there's not also
cheating scandals they're human but I
think if you look at if you look at
soldiers and think wow they kill people
they must be extremist I think that
really misunderstands what it's about
from the inside so no I think the
military is definitely a way of taking
people who are very diverse
psychologically and in terms of
identities and giving them an
overarching identity giving them a sense
of one for all all for one and I think
the military is interesting it should be
especially interesting to us now because
a it's one of the only institutions for
which there is still high regard and
Beor to whatever I said the first time
secondly is it's one of the most
successful at at addressing racial
problems and disparities so I think
they've been much more successful in the
academic world and there's a wonderful
book by to military sociologists called
all that we can be where they explain
how the military did it because they had
terrible racism up through the 70s and
once they realized why this is a serious
command problem this is a serious
readiness or operational problem that
are that were divided by race and racism
and they really addressed in an
intelligent way and they specifically
contrast what they did with what we do
with universities and say thank God we
didn't do it that way if I may say one
thing I was I was in the army and I
recall during basic training one time
where you had put your rifle over you
had in the end a shot kill kill kill
and I didn't want to kill anybody
because I didn't hate anybody and so did
others and they chose people based upon
how they responded to that those who did
not were not sent to combat but the
Solidarity that
John talk about is I saw the same thing
with the Taliban and the same thing with
the Mujahideen that you find that I
found in the military group solidarity
and the other is the enemy during in in
Vietnam era American soldiers called in
gooks and slant heads and in Afghanistan
I noticed they called them Hajis and
ragheads so there was this sense that
the unite the military had to
differentiate them differentiate
themselves from people who were once our
very close allies and one way they did
it inadvertently accidentally was by
same thing that soldiers did during my
era but was not but did the training
encouraged them to see them as subhuman
or is that since it emerges as people
are in convoy I'm convinced it merged
yeah we can do one last question
someone said early on that this group we
probably won't examine our own extremism
our own science and I found that to be
tremendously important is that something
that people are working on I mean our
own in-group is that something people
are working on is that something we
didn't you guys said we wouldn't do it
and we didn't yeah I mean I'll say two
things one is I have a close
collaborator who studies things like
descent and groupthink and the people
who are willing to speak up within their
own group when it's going wrong are the
people who identify actually most of the
group and they think they can see that
it's heading a direction that's gonna be
damaging to the group in the long run
there was a study that came out on this
last week it was in covered in The
Washington Post that people treat
in-group dissenters just as bad as out
group members and that this study was
done in the political domain and this is
why so you referenced you alluded to
John McCain you know when he spoke out
against God in conflict with Donald
Trump or a lot of Republicans treated
him very badly and his approval
plummeted into the same with Jeff Flake
in Arizona and this is a problem that is
a deeper psychological problem which is
that we have to think carefully about
embracing constructive in group
dissenters more wholly to avoid from
going astray and whatever level we
define
identity at whether that's at the
national level or at the university
level or political party level so I
think that self-examination is a
critical part of it but it turns out
it's really hard we don't treat people
who are self examining our group very
well thank you
well on that note I would like to just
say thank you - Jay - Kate - Jonathan -
Jerry this has been one of the most
interesting panels I've had the
privilege of ever moderating so thank
you guys so much - let's give everyone
you
[Music]